Rossy I haven't seen you yet where are
you this is like a major moment good
morning hi I'm just getting to the
offices here we're shooting our big
hairy Halloween show and guess what even
though I'm a judge on RuPaul's Drag Race
this is the first time I'm ever getting
in Drag and even better you're going to
come behind the scenes with me now I'm
going to start getting changed you don't
get to see this part okay so don't don't
laugh every but I had to put
on this before I uh do the hair and
makeup hi I'm Ross but soon I'll be
Dolly glue sticks aren't just for crafts
anymore you put glue stick on and then
you cover it with makeup and then we can
draw eyebrows higher like that when I
found out we were doing a hairy
Halloween all about Iconic Hair I was
like who can I be who can I be there's
nobody else for me to be but Dolly
Parton there's nobody better than her I
actually have always thought I look just
like
her love Dolly Parton with all my heart
I've been to Dollywood I rode every ride
I've interviewed her twice and the
restraining order still holds I can't
don't tell her I'm dressing as
her what would rup Paul say to you right
now oh oh God what would rup Paul
say don't get
up you know what if this is my first
time in drag I should probably call
somebody qualified for a little
advice
hello Nina West how are you look at you
soak her in it's the beginning of Dolly
listen I sit there as a super fan
judging on RuPaul's Drag Race but I've
never been put in drag myself so I need
advice Nina first of all how does it
feel so far is the word Fierce you're
feeling it no feeling it right now I can
see by the way you're looking at the
mirror you're already
[Applause]
like oh my gosh so first of all I for
your first time in drag I think you have
picked the very perfect person because
Dolly Parton as we know she's the queen
of kindness she's exudes heart she
exudes Soul she's country music's Rhythm
right she's the beat of country music
totally you know she's giving all of us
hope that's who Ross is Ross is a person
who is a beacon of love and joy so
you're not going to even find yourself
struggling with just being in drag
because you get to be yourself oh oh
Nina I'm so grateful will you be my drag
Mom are you kidding me I would be
honored are you serious I love you okay
okay everyone say bye
[Music]
Nina well hi it's me Dolly he guess what
it's showtime but first I have one more
call I have to
make ha babe it's me your husband
Lou I think Wellington said it best love
you
babe wow wow yeah should I leave the
costume on or no I'll take it off okay
bye okay now it's show time wish me
luck
[Music]
before we get started I'm not the only
Ross here today rossie I haven't seen
you yet where are
[Applause]
you this is like a major moment it's a
major moment and it's what we call
snatched
snatched I'm corseted and breathless
darling I can barely breathe but uh I'm
just going to say what you're all
thinking it's worth
[Applause]
[Music]
it